so hello hi everybody
hello the long-awaited Yousef and Jonny
guest appearance could you be on without
me I can't believe you did that
yeah it was while you were away and then
I missed your birthday
I remembered I've got you some coffee
not so well no I have to wait to see if
I'm allowed because you support two bags
one that needs grinding and one that
doesn't he grinding for two people and
you were lying around the grinder one
definitely has a right and one on Grindr
one is on Grindr so not even by his
choice yeah I already know where is mr.
long Grindr
I was I'm writing it twice cough oh geez
you've both cut fished in cut fish and
cut fished on Grindr yeah Binda in the
subject being another catfish on yonder
later on when we do our first step of
Q&A make sure you tune in for that
um when we do our first-ever Q&A did he
see that there's one question which
wasn't the question
it just said I wish he was I wish he
live close enough to me so that I could
find him on tinder in my radius you need
to expand you radius ultimately like you
know you need that's the tinder Pro or
you can just travel it off yourself
Kenya yeah that's oh speaking of tinder
we are going to talk about dating advice
today did did stay tuned it's something
that I've been relationships has been a
podcast we wanted to do for ages and
dating advice
yeah real long time dating advice for me
forms a nice foundation for that because
most people will go through the process
of dating someone that kind of you can
take it from the moment that you meet
someone that you may fancy open to the
point at which they become your
boyfriend or girlfriend and there's an
awful lot like that's a an area that
covers many sins right like from first
dates to seeing someone whatever the
[ __ ] that means to so we need to find
the relationship and from initial to
being exclusive with someone yeah but I
worry about from initial to
marriage yeah yeah exactly because I
would I would say arguably all of that
is technically in my mind I know that's
ridiculous
no no still kind of tango of like I said
I think it's all of its just arbitral
what is a relationship a relational evil
you know you've not litigated yourself
into a relationship until you're married
yeah yeah so but you know so all of this
we can try and conceptualize down so I
want you to do remove chronologically
then from single life all the way up to
hmm I want to leave single life and walk
this to make it super fresh note I mean
it makes me notes
sure I just want to organize my thoughts
sorry I couldn't I can do it to you long
lamomam linear I make notes now this
isn't a Russell Brand thing but I do
actually make note so I wanted to
pause it to you a bunch of things that
I've been thinking recently about well
you laughing what are you laughing it
just in these ghosts
what's SwiftKey but just not even to
talk cause answers
oh no it's that he's got a special
keyboard and we'll just leave him to
talk about it and that we can lifehacks
it come in in two weeks time listeners
and and viewers on the brand-new three
camera home YouTube set up 3d one two
tres the reason that I may seem a little
agitated is that Johnny was 50 minutes
late and use it was 19 minutes late and
we planned this for two weeks he's been
kind that I was more than ninety minutes
late okay despite having six seven days
notice yet for this it's fine so it's
good
moving on I wanted to talk about I
wanted to talk about sorry it's just
it's alright but you know you've got a
you've got a warm in warm and more warm
up good right so he's freezing cold go
on go go so I wanted to talk about
dating and what I've been thinking about
while I was away in America I ended up
having a chat with a young girl of a
node kind of been going through the
throes of her first serious relationship
and what came out of that was me making
some realizations and some rules about
my past behavior the girls could stick
to which would form a framework for them
to avoid bad guys and stick with good
guys so some heuristics that they can
follow yeah to keep them on their on the
right path I knew a bad guy or a good
guy in that I was I was the person who
you should avoid right and the reason
that I know the things that you need to
look out for and the very huge put in
place is because they were the ones that
would have tripped me up okay so this is
this is behind the curtain like this
isn't he this is the cheat codes of how
to get around [ __ ] reverse that
minute okay I would also like to contest
that further down the line over that you
are someone who you want to avoid
because I've you only know me
you only know me from what when I was 24
25 true I know that I'm talking I'm
talking like 18 to 23 so anyway I've
gotten so let me let me foundation it
for you every guy under the age of
around about 23 if you take the average
is not really worthy of being in a
relationship with and if you want to
have a relationship with someone who's
balanced and for it to last for a long
time as a girl I think that you're
fighting a losing battle I think that
under the age of 23 to 25 most guys
think with the penis first they don't
have a very solid understanding of who
they are and they're constantly chasing
after for the most part they're heavily
chasing after female attention to help
them bolster their own ego because they
don't have a concrete sense of character
about who they are anymore now obviously
there's going to be outliers in this
perfect example is my business partner
down so you may as missus in the second
year of uni I think they got together in
the third year they're moved in when
they were 21 22 they got a dog when they
were 25 they got married when they were
26 ago another dog at 27 they had they
got a kid at 29 or 28 and now they're in
this amazing house and they very
systematic progression yeah is the
perfect framework the equivalent of the
American Dream but like marriage and
college sweetheart like it yeah it
they're got it but they're the outliers
especially for him he's the absolute
rarity in this situation so I think a
lot of the time people who don't
understand what I do my job now as a
club promoter is actually more as just a
leader and a glorified parent so I'm
pretty much a big brother to between 250
and 500 students in Newcastle or
Manchester every single year and every
year I get older but they stay the same
age they just get replaced this is just
this conveyor belt of new people coming
in and the same set
relations come up over and over and over
and over again and these people who work
for you or people who work for me right
not people in the clubs no I'm not close
enough to the player they're in the
clubs but these are people who are in
the clubs they're just ones that I've
course it's because you tell them
anything you tell people you tell people
to get across the club see exactly
you've that's the correct framework so I
think one of the first things that girls
need to be really conscious of and I'm
gonna I'm going to do guys
hey I'm going to do guys as well I'm
gonna give advice to guys got it I'm
gonna go for girls first is that your
foundation there as well I think you
said that going for a man under 23 and
expecting someone who is stable and
emotionally mature and reliable for a
relationship purpose is a losing battle
because statistically they're not going
to be I think and I remember you discuss
this as well which is that there's a the
the curves of when men and women
emotionally mature don't overlap
properly and I think by age 23 there's a
stark difference in like there's
probably both genders have a surge
period where they do emotionally mature
but they don't coincide and so you can
end up with an absolute idiot don't I'm
so hearing how you got there but the
thing is that at the age of about 21 I
would say that the vast majority of guys
are still our souls and girls are still
psychos
now I know that's colloquially termed
but everyone who's listening knows why
me the girls have had the hearts broken
by some guy who didn't know how to treat
them correctly maybe once maybe a couple
of times the trust in men is just
through the floor guys have realized
that if like sex has conquest and trying
to like that's what Khasra yeah guys are
guys in numbers on a shirt on the
notches on the headboard and just spray
about as much as possible
sprayer so I've had this discussion with
this girl in America and I was just
having a little bit to think about what
it is the
need to be wary of him basically what is
the format you know on this podcast we
talk about life hacks we try and lay out
in as simple and conceptual away as
possible how you can be optimal right
and what's the best way to behave in the
world and this may not be the best way
but it's the best way that I can think
of so it's worth me like saying to you
guys right it's working articulating the
first thing that I think that girls need
to do when they start speaking to guys
and this is in you've met them in a club
or you've like match them on tinder or
you've started chatting to them from
work or whatever it might be when you
first begin speaking to them I think
that girls get too much of a bad rap for
giving lads a hard time and making them
jump through hoops personally for me I
don't think they're making them jump
high enough like I think that the
hurdles that are laid down by girls for
men especially when you're talking 20 21
22 23 and butt up to you know but
throughout the whole way through life I
think the high that the hurdles are as
long as you are making sure that the man
knows that you're interested and that
you're giving them sufficient attention
to know that they're going to continue
to play the game I think it's a win-win
scenario including for the men right let
me tell you why so firstly if you're
laying down and by laying down hurdles
what I mean is not folding or
compromising on something that you think
when they do something wrong you tell
them straight away and you put them in
that place when they make plans and they
cancel them you don't need to go
overboard you don't need to be
passive-aggressive and we'll get onto
that in a second because that is the
number one way to remove the integrity
of what you're saying right passive
aggressiveness for me is up there with
the top knowledge that you should the
girls should do in relationships and
guys at work by laying down these
hurdles for girls the first thing that
it does is it certifies that the guy who
you're speaking to is invested in you in
the long term if they're not prepared to
get past you asking them a question
about their last relationship or you
asking them to make plans for a night
out if you ask them okay
let's go out on wedding day but I'm
going to let you plan the date I'll plan
the next one but you plan the date and
you turn up and he then says I've got
nothing planned you need to tell them
that you've [ __ ] up you need to say
that [ __ ] that's not that's not a good
investment in your time so it's the the
example there is is having a principal
and making sure that the principle is
upheld draw some hard lines in the sand
of what isn't is not acceptable behavior
so I think I've seen both ends of the
spectrum where either there is [ __ ]
testing for [ __ ] testing sake and it
almost is like it's contrived it's just
trying to give someone a hard time for
the sake of it but there's no real
underlying principle
very similar to if you've seen the
argument clinic on Monty Python where he
goes into the room he's like hello am I
in the right room for an argument is
like they want you can you bring the
other leg much [ __ ] testing is place for
people yeah Joe Perry ultimately well so
yeah let's go on to think of our street
as well but yeah so [ __ ] testing just
what you've said giving someone a like a
hard time or to see how they respond but
yeah it's very good it's the purpose of
doing that though right he only for that
without an underlying it's the female
equivalent of negging right yeah so so
the and what my point is it has to be a
certain agenda and that has to be a
stable set of principles it's not
something born out of integrity whereas
at one point in the argument clinic he's
like no doesn't yes there's no hang on
this isn't no you man this is just
contradiction you like no it isn't yes
it is my argument is a series of
statements performed around a specific
foundational point whereas you're just
desaad like disagreeing with everything
that I say and so there's the difference
I think like if it's if it's upholding a
certain set of values yes then yeah
you're totally right and that's then
done something that I've missed and and
the other side of it is just being it
needs to it needs to be borne of what
you what do you consider as it go to be
acceptable and unacceptable behavior in
a month then draw the lines in the sand
and don't compromise them so here's the
reasons it's good that
you are going to make sure that the men
that you invest your time in a
sufficiently invested in you because the
ones who fall at the first hurdle and
aren't prepared to get over it what do
you think was gonna [ __ ] happen when
they're drunk in a nightclub and some
girl comes up to them like this is it's
making sure that they can bear a
sufficiently heavy load even a [ __ ]
empty bar level of a heavy load that
when they have to go into a 1 rep max in
terms of virtue that they might actually
have the capacity to bear it that makes
sense just looking at their bar speed
when the bar is empty this is probably
gonna go up we're headed a few bills
there's gonna be like to CrossFit girls
so ok so that's the that's the first
thing that's good
before we move on yeah these these
principles if we are for someone who's
listening yeah does this apply so I
think that has to be a conversation of
like
is this person looking for a one-night
stand scenario or are they looking to
move towards about have I jumped ahead
no no you've asked they give us the
perfect question oh because I have
because I think you have to begin with
the end everything if if as a girl all
that you're mapping if you if you if you
want a posting as a girl like crack on
find a guy that is low the barriers but
low the below the barriers but height in
the standards like because if you want a
one-night stand your parameters for what
you're looking for in a mate and change
yeah in election you how bother bothered
are you but in terms of you probably
look what someone is a bit lean you
probably want someone who's muscular who
physically fits the attributes that you
need whereas you know we've all been
around beautiful but stupid people right
and vice versa really interesting people
who are not sexually attracted to and I
find that dynamics so interesting
because if you ask the most women and
women if you're listening and disagree
please save they're like any woman I've
spoken to you have asked would you have
sex with a man who you find physically
attractive but was really bored you it
was boring of hell as opposed to someone
who you maybe but you found attractive
but you hated and they prefer to have
sex with a man who they hated because at
least the Sun intensity there's some
personal feeling whereas I think men are
much different in the sense that like
you could have sex with someone that you
found quite boring I think I'm a nurse
came out to a very mechanical an
interaction was really women less so
much more visceral yeah man right so are
the perfectly correct if all that you're
looking for is sex then change your
parameters around so this is a different
that's yes I'm talking about I'm talking
about date
I wouldn't say view okay I wouldn't
class dating it's if you need to go out
on the pool mhm then we will do and if
you want a podcast on that then we'll do
a podcast on how to be single like how
this isn't this isn't trading it's
investing this isn't exactly this is no
trading it's not short term positions
this is I'm looking for a long term yes
position for a fact yeah so it's not
very helpful either on crypto is yeah
like yeah yeah exactly you're not you're
not margin trading you're not doing
fifty twelve creation
yes exactly so hopefully that made it
much clearer so that's the first thing
that's good right and so it means that
you filter out the bottom feeders
mmm-hmm the menu aren't worth your time
and you you jump ahead a couple of steps
so cool
second thing that's good is it sets a
tone for the relationship moving forward
that means that you're not going to take
[ __ ] mm-hmm so we all know and we'll
gather this when we do relationships the
proper relationships podcast for me the
key
in almost every relationship it's like
the first six weeks to 10 weeks the
reason being that you set precedent
after precedent after precedent for what
happens in Ex situation and why
situation in Zedd situation what happens
when you don't get a message after
someone's being on a night out saying
that they've got home safe and how do
you react how do you react when they get
in late how do you react when they
cancel a date how do you react when they
do whatever so I forgot to say that
particular camera can only do around
about 20 minutes at a time okay every so
often okay are you gonna pass it on to
you I'm gonna have to get up and we have
to change it Thanks video guy Dean you
know pass it on to us when we speak and
then I'm gonna get it right to that if
you're just listening that's completely
pointless but it's fine so it sets the
tone for the relationship moving forward
right it means that you are drawing
lines in the sand not only for now that
filter out potential mates but you're
also training them to be a good mate for
you the third and final one and this is
the one that I think is most holistic
moving forward is men really in fact
that I'm going to make this into a four
thirdly men really [ __ ] need this
the reason being that it makes them
learn what isn't is not acceptable
behavior for women like if they're if
you are with a guy and you find out that
he's been messaging you mate and you
think that that based on your own values
and your own integrity you think that
that is unacceptable behavior and you've
been him off that's only gonna happen to
him two or three times before he goes I
probably need to change my behavior the
reason that this continues to happen is
that if guys were able to weed all the
way through and this is speaking from
experience because for years and years
and years I was able to outwit girls
that I was seeing to one degree or
another whatever level of depth you want
to say that is and I was able to I was
able to get myself out of it so I never
learned this is the Parkinson's Law like
in a social context of Parkinson's Law
is where you and task fills at the time
that you've allocated to it and I'm sure
if you've been working to a deadline
with an essay or something you like for
some reason you there's no way you can
just kind of done a week in advance in a
two-hour slide before itch yeah always
extends to that and the same thing like
if a certain behavior is permitted
frequently then you lower your own
standards for your secretaries No so as
a man you want someone to hold you to a
higher standards like Earl Nightingale
says the treat a man as you expect him
to be not as he is and you know give him
the room to expand to that and terraza
what our perfect challenge so that that
quote has managed to make a good
synopsis I think of everything that I've
come on with you so what I think if I
had I think as a 21 year old or than
younger like 20 year old I was too
ego driven to probably realize the I I
think is a young guy you take a lot of
advice like this or I know this is named
two cars in this part or is it look big
Chloe it should be because I should
realize they can make implications from
this mmm the vast majority of the
audience that's listening to this maybe
two-thirds of it mmmm oh okay I think
one of the behaviors you've covered
there's a flip side on me to an eternal
erections and I think that men should be
interested in why women are motivated
the way that they are and women should
be vice versa and men should hold women
to the highest standard behavior as well
just gonna gets it okay oh yeah yeah I
do I think the I think it's hard to as a
guy that age when I think you're finding
your like your own feelings and your own
beliefs and a lot of areas like this
like whatever I think is true in these
situations are forming judgments based
on experiences and someone says actually
women you know a woman should treat me
like this I think a lot of guys when
faced with higher standards or sort of a
framework that they have to operate in
sort of resistant and go for the person
who's not doing that
lowest hanging fruit yeah because it
lasts easier yeah but they don't to be
challenged with that but again as girls
do you want to be the low-hanging [ __ ]
for another I think ourselves now we go
back we go back to the first the first
advantage that you get the fact that you
filter out the guys that aren't worth
your time and if again with this there's
kind of like a curve right so one-night
stand is this particular level and then
I want marriage is this particular level
and then anywhere in between there's
some yeah Jun Durst and so you can go
okay well I can lay down lines in the
Sun that are sufficiently hard as I need
to button imagine if tomorrow every
woman on the planet a deed to a similar
framework as this there would be a loan
understand that there would be able to
there would be a lot raise sex for a
long time but imagine where men would be
in 20 years it's like it's rickety's but
don't you want if you want to have sex
with a woman
you have and if you want to be in a
relationship with a woman you have to
learn how to treat me correctly you have
to learn what isn't is not acceptable
behavior
and if you [ __ ] up you will be better
for the next woman who comes around so
this is this is coming from a this whole
conversation is coming from a
perspective of like women are the on the
victim side of this equation like men
mistreat women that men of the sexual
protagonists and then in women give
access so to that women women women
female women that's probably correct
statement they are the female kind human
females is why men got it human females
are the only females in the animal
kingdom they're sexually selective right
okay so everyone else is just if a
chimpanzees on heat shield mate with the
alpha male hmm but only because he's
they're going given the object given the
opportunity yeah she'll mate with any
male when chessani okay the only reason
that meant to the alpha male is because
there's a threat violence and because
they're thinkers they're available
pigs but press and they will be obeyed
does he's got the biggest bench
Rossiter's so and I'm gonna now move on
to women mate across and up dominance
hierarchies okay right what - what - men
mate across and up across and down using
men just may across the town so they
never they've ever shoot when you say
DOM and hierarchies you mean like I'm a
seven out of ten there are nine out of
ten is that you mean on that level of
aces or what do you mean not subtractive
this isn't it that's what I'm trying
again like what I mean about dominant
hierarchy in this so it's it's it's how
you have raised yourself up through the
social how high your social equity is if
I get waiting you could blow it so
dominance hierarchy is and the reason
for this is you have twice as many
mothers
trip illogically evolutionarily as you
do man y'know a fact addint right so
what that means is that on average in
history now every woman has had one
child and every other man has had to go
that make sense got it so you have
what's called a Pareto distribution
which is nothing nothing nothing
everything and that's because human
males
are chosen at the top of the dominance
hierarchy so you have losers and you
have winners mm-hmm
whereas with females the distribution is
more even that make sense yeah yeah and
the reason for that is that men mate
across and down then women are mate
across and up so what let's let's take a
very basic example of this so I'm a
really really attractive woman mmm
right I know it's hard to imagine let's
say very shapely let's say I'm just
remembering it's not just we're not just
talking attractive I serious
no no yeah all right but ok so I
consider myself as a result of that and
my social status to be pretty high so I
would then rather sleep with someone a
mate with someone who I perceived to be
of a higher social status than me or a
level or on a level almost in spite of
what they look like necessarily so like
if someone it depends on it depends on
how the dominance hierarchy will usually
be influenced by looks as well right ok
they'll be in a bit if there are
multiple overlapping dominance
hierarchies insert so like rather than
having one big one that all of humanity
follows that would mean that only one
person would reach the top and it was a
competition to be so stiff and so we
create more than one over yeah within
different social circles so if you're
working in if you're a if you're a
solicitor then like that you operate a
different hierarchy too if you're a
bodybuilder and then all these things
and we create our own so the
characteristic time it's like
geographical and within friendship
circles and so his name again
absolutely but at the extreme what I was
trying to get up is you see you have
this image it's like people joke about
it of like the the really fantastic
attractive model who's married to a guy
who is 80 years old but extremely well
known man she's not my envelope well
okay but but she sees him as a very high
social status to degree but I still
don't think that she's marrying for look
that's that's marrying or being in a
relationship without integrity again
okay so that's contrary to this this
model to degree yeah
I don't think she's marrying up and
across dominance hierarchies I think
she's marrying up and across income
hierarchies maybe she's just waiting for
the footages of torment it's a form of a
dominance hierarchy but yeah and the
agenda there is skewed because like the
typical gold digger thing is like you're
waiting for someone to die so that you
can inherit a mother the income may be
associated with like social status but
they're still there - it's like yeah
okay so there's maybe some that like the
idea of it dragging them up a little bit
so um you took surely an interesting
point and I can imagine that some people
who might be thinking that this does
sound like men of the sexual addresses
and women are victims these maidens in
waiting right but we cannot get away
from the fact
that women are the ones that make the
decision to say yes or no
broadly okay they have to bear a greater
biological load foot absolutely I start
in my experience sorry better ones
they're the ones that make the decision
broadly okay yeah they're the ones that
get to say yes or no so what that means
is that there are more men prepared to
have sex with the women with women than
there are women prepared to have sex
with men and this is the reason for this
you have on average one mother and two
do you know I mean enough half the
number of fathers as you do pair as you
do mothers okay so the implication of
that for men
by interesting I think actually like
what does that mean as a man that you
should be doing it means that first off
if you want to be successful with women
by lookup I crook the dominance
hierarchy is probably a pretty good
place to start
it's kind of like waving a flag above
your head
mm-hmm and you know this I'll link I'll
make sure that I'll link in me show not
below some of the studies about the
mating like across and above an
accordion rugby but as a man you almost
set a glass ceiling based on your own
position within this dominance hierarchy
there was something that you said which
is really like sort of Crayola example
of this which was like I'm single and I
don't know why but like I've got a job I
can't drive
what is up trying to find that I'll have
to take that because it was really well
worried if there was someone yet so
maybe the flip side of that is someone
saying as a man if you read books lift
weights dress well and smile and
instantly in the top 20 percent line
like it's the bar at the bar is said the
ground and so going above that is like
incredibly well and you know very
briefly to go back to the thing about
who gets to choose to have sex
mhm perfect perfect example here is Gay
Pride was recently moving through the UK
mmm and I've got a number of gay friends
who've been to a number of gay prides
and they say to me so you know lads lots
on lights out and usually you think
either up for it they're up for it and
really the only hurdle they have to get
over is whether or not the women are
again I know that we're regressing back
a little bit just to say it's no sake of
it under summing it yeah I agree that
for the purposes of just sex and
presuming that that's the first place
they go to that then leads to a
relationship whereas with women it may
be a little bit more of a slow take off
yeah
imagine that the decision-makers are
women mmm now remove the decision-maker
and replace that with another man missin
making you imagine what it's like it get
pride this is coming from the [ __ ]
source oh yeah yeah this may not be
representative of all gay prides and I'm
sure that there's some men out there
that play hard to get
Jesus Christ men like to shagger the men
yeah like they really really like to
[ __ ] the man and you got like the gay
pride events and these are the stories
that I hear back and they're like some
of the things that these guys he I like
harrowing really I just can't believe
how much [ __ ] sex these guys are
because I listen to the gay bar you get
touched up so much do you know okay I
don't know how that experience might
just be meaner but you should take Chris
Michael gay bar did they think did they
think that you are the low-hanging fruit
I don't know you already like [ __ ]
little in your party pants a nose
piercing slightly exotic I get a lot of
I get more male attention than female
I'm sure what do you think that says
about you I think that's true for me
eternity but I don't not in a gay bar by
night cause you've got like in the
Otterness face but you all my other
beings quite like angular please tells
me yesterday
try to tell me that his language
vocabulary is put what's knio knio
sinners like a so cherub like you like
like a younger face alright
but like the this is this as other
people's words not Nelson that's
necessary if you were being like oh like
he's he's got the face of an angel and
the body of a demon that sounds like the
sort of thing that you find any message
requests on the instant okay so because
of that but I get very tonight why do
you think I said well on speculating
like I do you've got some soft features
okay yeah it's nice it's kind of like it
the real case of benjamin button but
only from the neck up okay you're
regressing
I like the little cherub you know you
are can we track strap you to a trivia
so I would rather not I wasn't it I was
in a gym in Kenton Park Laser Center I
think those cages around the secure
two cameras and this man was big guy
telling us about his time in jail on a
steroid use and stuff he looks over at
Johnny here's your lovely I think you've
been busy I feel like if he wanted you
even [ __ ] you worth you were his yeah
there and there I was doing he was just
wrapping than overall cement yeah he was
an ounce doing snatch is your Henton gym
doing snatch doing stuff with this small
thick mess with flight sealer plates
yeah so we've done that
yeah quit further but which I think good
point there and then you know talking
about that the example about men men on
men men on men sex that's example that
you say me grinder has a location
feature oh but it's within meters I'm
really if I'm gonna turn down a location
feature not find the woman that you've
matched with well I think Brian did just
has like a it's like a radar it does I
mean do they like Call of Duty or
something like it's like tells you
everyone in so ISM so does that mean
that men are predatory alone if there's
a nominal status of like a predation on
in gay scenes than in like a yes what
what happens on you think you're a
predator and you turn up in your your
huge hundred and sixty bench guy from
chem and Jim's there is you know like
you've been operating it so this is more
hunters being hunted yeah exactly
by that logic you wouldn't might mean
tempted yeah fair enough you just said
yeah well no because you might be a
bummer but not by me and so that's the
that's the dynamics in mechanics that I
I'm upon again - can really be ignorant
you need to have a articulate game on
yeah coming I would love one is down
without me to like how do you know
whether you're above me Europe I'm a
well no I think you though I think you
know which one you are
how do you know which one that is
profile yeah yeah what's the metrics
around a bar what was lost the top or
bottom
yeah you just for that like on Grindr is
it right I feel like I'm just
why did you get the proof I was at a
party in this town for each we've hit
the button over there certain right we
have to guess it still this is still
dating we have to get a a gay man that
is happy to talk about the intricacies
of I've got a couple that could be
really really good nice tonight yeah
don't be awesome and then we can
discover this is mrs. K playground for
me but uh
tomforde there's a fashion is our
designer has a theory that all straight
men should be but Emily plainly
penetrated it's quite a good
justification for this but he does have
an agenda doesn't even increase the pool
because America loves why if use a
straight line without opinion fair
enough that's the arc it's the other way
you would say that obviously it's the
argument that Bret Weinstein and Heather
hang say when they're talking about sex
at dawn by Chris Ryan mm-hmm
so Chris Chris Ryan saying basically
everyone anthropologically is built to
be polyamorous is a really really good
way to just get women to sleep with you
so okay so we've you know we've laid out
a bit of a framework what what your what
your thought to that well so that that's
what pickup artistry is and I suppose
telling people to be polyamorous is
trying to sideline and subvert this this
existing system so that you can cash in
on it and pickup artistry essentially is
the same thing but it's convincing
someone for a short enough period that
you are someone who you are not maybe
higher on on a dominance hierarchy that
is relevant to the so usually like
clubbing and that kind of thing yeah and
hold on you catch up yeah ah my session
or the clubbing and that's what of disco
okay but so I've got friends who were
really into pickup artistry for some
time
and there's one guy he's a German guy
and I really good-looking like looks
like a test-tube baby like and he was
convinced that it was the picker pasture
but I think it was just the fact that
he's a good-looking confident
and it just it just even things to so I
think pick apart against a terrible name
because terrible name is in the name
remedial artistry is trying to just pick
up girls right the whole point is they
two notches on the bedpost and miss than
the other but you could look at pickup
artistry from a whole number of other
angles right like what I've done over
the last three years with the people
that listen to and the things that I've
read has made me a better potential
partner unequivocally so any girl that I
spend time with and it meant that my
ability to become in a relationship with
women has also improved as a result it
was just understanding myself to an
introspective or I see all the rest of
so is that pickup artistry
well pickup artistry is not one thing I
suppose and it's evolved over the years
like from from my friend Lenny I'm sure
he won't mind like is it was very
algorithmic it was very and he was a
computer scientist who's very like
vocally not an apple yeah you say this
and then you you alpha the the toad and
then you nag them whatever and these are
the lemon and it's like this was all it
was all very formulaic and he found that
it made him quite depressed in fight
who's it was him and someone else for
thee the other guy I'm thinking of said
that he made him feel very depressed
because it created this disconnect
between the person that he had to put
across to be attractive to women and the
person who he really was
yeah it's like being able to lift on
performance-enhancing drugs and I'm
coming off of the amount
oh [ __ ] I'm still really really weak
whereas what I've done is I've done a
strength protocol naturally and brought
my brought my strength up to a level
where I feel more capable mmm know me
Montmartre Manson's book quote models
which is fantastic so it comes under
that bracket that is very different well
it's more about authenticity
loyalty so he talks about dying diet
training he talks about like stop
masturbating God me that use that energy
to go out and meet people gives his
argument is that guys don't have a model
and surname to interact with women and
so they trials pickup artistry stuff and
forget that actually like you have to be
a valuable desirable thing
I say this isn't to say that women are
neither of course women women also need
to add value hmm but again for this by
then I think there's an I think women
naturally but a lot more care in their
appearance and on that side of things I
would our if I would go as far as to say
that I think women on the whole are more
virtuous than men when it comes to
relationships that may be a
controversial thing to say but I do
think that it's the truth especially at
the younger age brackets hmm they put in
more effort overall like from how many
how many girls do you know that have
cheated on men versus men their few
young girls cuz I know it - the 1 or 3
to 1 ratio is elite men - what do you
think the motivations are different
between why men cheat and why women
cheat yeah so yeah I remember who it was
some relationships guy saying men cheat
because they want sex or they want
variety women cheat because they feel if
not attended to enough so here we here
we go have you let me use the Family Guy
analogy before oh yes is my favorite
analogy that I use for dating there's a
lot of women I [ __ ] love this Rice's
are clearly quite its marker so anyone
who's watched Family Guy before Peter
stood at the window watching Bonnie
who's Joe's wife out of the window he's
got binoculars he's looking at it and
changed out of the window and he's
making like under his voice going like
she's really hot so I'm making my move
you yeah and then Stewie comes it he
walks along to the sign he goes what are
you doing fat man looks at him he goes
looks out to the window he sees Bonnie
game changing he goes I don't understand
you've got this smoking hot wife at home
why would you be looking at oh I see it
doesn't need to be better it just needs
to be different mm-hm and the value of
novelty in a relationship of something
new hmm
cannot be understated biochemically
speaking as well I think it's it we can
get onto that yeah the genetic lottery
as its world yeah but the value of
novelty can't be understated it doesn't
need to be better it just needs to be
different and I think that's so much
cheating from men can be explained by
that so another is hyperbolic
discounting
without a relative so it's so cheating
is the reason that people cheat
from my perspective from like a
behavioral perspective is its failure to
see the the power and the value of a
long-term outcome long term cost or
benefit and not being able to discount
not appropriately the short term short
term positive for long but also I think
like especially guys the number of the
guys who I knew it was like cheated and
like you've even thought about cheating
and I cheated it's it's the narrative of
they are better different more
interesting funnier more attractive
whatever but I just think there's a
fixed trajectory the relationships take
and it's just starting that a process
again like month one month two great so
because I'm at there's so much stuff
that we can go into here I'm gonna let
you do the bit about the genetic lottery
do you know yeah do you know the Brett
Weinstein and Heather hanging thing
about I've not seen that okay what right
what I can I'll be able to lead you I
was going to talk about the the
dopaminergic sensitivity yes yeah cool
so but before that hmm I was on love
island right and we Bonilla what's been
a hundred thousand people have seen the
podcast we do um
link will be audios to or here video
guide II I think was too long to be
honest laughing you know throughout the
five percent 5 percent of people that
commented said the same I think it was
really surprising to hear that you were
intelligent Chris and I think it was or
the in the comic it may be I think I
thought I think that I want to know what
gear that guy that's close to the camp
yeah that guy that guy's full of t-ball
on water deep armed water well yeah
that's exactly that's exactly this guy
and I'm not gonna say who this and he'd
recently split up with his girlfriend
after cheating on her a number of times
and he said this sentence to me so the
two frameworks that have borne so much
of my understanding about relationships
are doesn't need to be better it just
needs to be different and then this
interaction that I had with
love island mm-hmm being with this girl
for maybe two or three years kept on
cheating on it captain cheetah
captain Sheena it couldn't stop for some
reason you go and get drunk sir okay
like rule number one don't get drunk
like um pariah Paragon I have a paragon
of sobriety okay
and so that's easy for me to say right
but if you keep on [ __ ] cheating any
girl from when you get drunk
stop cheating on it mm-hmm like I
stopping getting drunk all right if
that's the trigger then you've got what
mainly it's not it's difficult in the
pirate heads yes on the phone exactly
and he said this sentence to me and he
was saying you know it is I loved it a
bit I love it but I just can't keep my
dick in my pants I looked at bits I just
can't keep my dick in my pants between
it doesn't need to be better it just
needs to be different and I looked at a
bit I can't keep my dick in my pants
you have the framework as far as I'm
concerned so he's not unhappy in his
relationship you just he is unable to
counteract his urges to degree and you
think okay so what does that say he was
at the time 24 25 something great Willy
yeah Willy come with with that coming
with that wait until he's older so that
mature
wait until he's matured and just take it
on the chin the sexual drive that a
particulate that that particular person
needs to make some mistakes right and as
a girl we're going back to being as a
girl and as a guy as well as a girl the
implication is allowing to make mistakes
but not with you hmm
as a guy allow yourself to spread your
royal seed as much as you want but don't
put yourself through the emotional
turmoil of thinking that you can be in a
long-term relationship with a girl if
you just demonstrate that you've got
repeat yeah what does the evidence
suggest the evidence suggests that I
love this girl to bit but I can't stop
shagging other girls okay so stop doing
the tomato sauce - yeah I love yourself
to imagine Johnny foto I'm crushed
so I think why that breaks down is it's
what I don't know that was a puzzle it
implies that because if we're getting
into monogamy you only do they great
weather yeah it's possible yeah I think
probably and I don't know this is a wild
punt but I would imagine the highest
percentage of cheating happens in
relationships where people have been
people are in their 40s or 50s
be married a while the spark has
completely gone from a relationship and
that's when a lot of us I think I don't
know there's a big breakdown of stats
around cheating of complete I'll have to
find it the other point Oh in fact the
radio palace video guy Dean will make
sure that Dean that we will have those
stats floating on the screen so these
nights of these starts right here it's
these starts to be part of those higher
incidence of cheating with attractive
couples which kind of makes sense I
guess but because they've got better
access maybe that's it
maybe they feel more desirable I think
there's also that there's a it's an
immature game that some some women play
and presumably some men as well I'm sure
you've you have seen we're gonna do this
sounds like you feel
shopping there's something out of line
actually no husband has happened to me
but yeah so women who will deliberately
look for men who are in a relationship
trying to see him yeah almost as a sense
of like accomplishing just the edge to
know that they can I was once in a club
this girl came up to me and started
being like really forthcoming with me
like straight like the straight away I'm
like okay I would have loved to have
seen
help help matters arc and when making
upstairs came upstairs like basically
dragging me up her satochi pickup
artistry okay and she and then she came
up to her boyfriends and it was like she
was clearly just trying to make him
jealous finding the first guy that she
saw like I'm gonna get punished together
by yes should assign them to the
appropriate protocol excuse me when I'm
gonna yeah well he wouldn't have signed
up if you had if you gotta 160 bench she
wouldn't she would never got to find you
if he'd been on perfect protocol
okay program fitness come forward slash
just perfect protocol hooker broken
protocol to comp there we go pull the
domain Dean Dean so much
so moving on with segwayed here but I do
that bit I feel like we were doing a bit
we do we're gonna move on to the
monogamy thing but this is gonna be a
evolutionary basis for monogamy cool so
anyone who's read sex at dawn by Chris
Ryan wolf not okay
so unknown August recommendation right
yeah well all Barry Marcus said the
first time that he touched another woman
that wasn't his wife he was physically
sick and the first time his wife brought
someone else home sounds great all day
yeah thank you see see see sees that day
mate get the book at first yeah it was
for a dry retching for four weeks and
but I broke through the barrier and
actually now it's really rewarding
alright anyway okay cool just [ __ ]
story or break you know where he is at
the moment it's in the middle of the is
in Peru having little drink between this
year don't you read some especially over
and over again so anthropological basis
for monogamy there's a to preface this
mmm there is I think it's called
explained on Netflix and it is a series
of 10 to 50
minute videos on a variety of subject is
on a k-pop there's one it's something
else and there's one on monogamy right
Chris Ryan's on that and if you want to
find out a little bit more about why he
believes there is this any worse
evolutionary basis for humans being
monogamous monogamous watch that or read
his book sex at dawn or listen to Brett
Weinstein and Heather hang on Joe Rogan
and they do a really lovely little
breakdown of them but not the Chris
Brian he's like the Geordie SAS guy he
was with Andy McNab different well not
to sound Radio one but that's Chris
Morris Moyles see pop culture is lacking
in this way I mentioned Netflix yes the
other podcast and I was really proud I
watched a series on Netflix the other
day because you go from really good yeah
yeah so this is a TED talk again the so
many resources but it's called I think
it's called your brain on porn or it's
something about that psychiatrist and
talking about an increase or an influx
of young man with a reptile dysfunction
usually comorbid with depression anxiety
those kind of things and he thinks it's
because of the increase in internet porn
and he says that this is based on a rat
study but they took a male rap
introduced a female rat measured its
arousal response by like penile
circumference and measured how that
changed over time over time it so it
rose above baseline and then it became
slowly desensitized to the female rock
introduced a new female rat and it went
above baseline doesn't need to be better
yep it was just different
it kept doing that and it kept going
above baseline but less and less until
it became tolerant to the novelty of the
stimulus and eventually it went below
baseline and so it wasn't able to attain
the same level of arousal that it did
first time and he says that we're doing
this on a mass basis where we have
unfettered access to a far greater rate
of sexual novelty than you normally
would in Gen
human interaction and the rate rate of
porn being produced far outpaces the
Raby you could watch it even on
double-speed I love that we can set out
you're like no one could keep up with
you know for me it's manufac when you
think about that it's very yeah yeah did
we ever do that podcast where a site
you'd load of pornhub stats
I think it did it's a great start
slavery brave when you start down there
yeah everyone I really clever confident
why I think they do that you can't
market economy can't out the times
people just organic shares easily
produce that and people start telling
their mates about it yeah the only thing
I think our well there's the thing you
don't ever I've never been online and
someone's sent me a link and been like
what's this what's this ain't xhamster
calm the only slash a bit / the dinner
mmm so it's like okay have you got any
more what to say that so he says that
what happens there is that this we reset
our baseline sensitivity to sexual
stimulus but also to general reward and
the porn addiction doesn't necessarily
even come out of wanting account of a
sexual drive anymore it comes out of
like just wanting some kind of emotional
excitement and some something to do
can I bore them it could be connection
and could be like and and so people
start watching weirder weirder like vice
I can be seen Randy in South Park where
he starts out like he doesn't get any
porn for ages and then he starts it like
Brazilian fart porn work where he tells
quagmire it's my Sephora Chris file yeah
and so to move on for men you can get
poor you can't quite so his is one of
the things that I want to move on to in
this and one of the problems is you may
be able to jump in and actually provide
a framework for men that they can lay
down for women as I have done women for
men I haven't been able to and I haven't
gotten in my head well I do have is a
bit of advice for men who want to date
and I'd be interested to your thoughts
on this okay so
men who are outside of the norm let's
say that there's a bell curve
distribution of people who are normal
and my normal that is similar interests
similar mindset similar everything like
nine-to-five job like football
everything yeah whatever it might be
wherever that where the median Falls
wherever the median Falls they're closer
to that yep by its very definition the
deeper that you are as a person the more
contrary subtle or alarming your views
are going to be society at large I love
the idea of an alarming review yeah
you're all right you're right and given
the choice between acceptability and
honesty most of us usually would choose
the former hmm okay so very under button
[Laughter]
button and you know why that is if it is
it's a direct quote from our King why
were you born she said it so quickly on
the bottom so the video that I'm citing
here is one called why we are fated to
be lonely by school of life it's six
minutes long I must have watched it
about a hundred times I'll make sure
it's linked in the show notes by cannot
advise anyone who's a person of death to
watch anything more a completely
reframed my thought on this and this is
for advice for guys who perhaps don't
fit into what would be a typical
category and if you are someone who's a
little bit of an enigma to one degree or
another that it doesn't fit into the
archetypal role for instance is a good
example is why I always talk about with
yourself like Tom know yeah what that's
why the top not works okay because
clean-cut often wear navy but oh my god
he's got a top knot oh my god he can
deadlift 310 kilos why is he a chartered
accountant why does he run his own
business do you know I mean yeah it
isn't that enigma is what makes things
interest I think even without the
top-most it's really say you know this
ain't the same for all of us to one
degree or another and I think that's why
we all get on the lane leasco
it smoking you are the you are the
outlier you are an outlier amongst
outliers
so and here's my thing right so way says
is that a certain degree of loneliness
is a kind of tax that we have to pay to
atone for a certain complexity of mind
that makes sense what this means is it
can lead to a special man that have got
a particular level of depth to actually
struggle dating finding connections with
other people and what I want this
particular section of the podcast to do
is to not only champion that kind of an
approach for men to further themselves
in life and in dating and in a bunch of
other things but also to get them to
really dig their heels into what they
what they believe in and who they are I
think it's important to first
distinguish whether if you listen to
this you're like you're not just like oh
yeah the reason I can't get any female
attention is just because I'm such an
indie world it's so deep man like you
die just and yeah is that just I've got
these thoughts and they go around in my
head like yes yeah it's like making the
distinction and having being objective
enough to say is it because of that that
I'm unable to find a mate or is it I
wish I could find that quote because it
put it it's like I can't parallel park
um my my t-shirts are always dirty I
haven't got a job and I'm single and
I've got no idea one buzzer so yeah okay
so like like please clean the clean your
room if I need the basic basic stuff
getting rid of the low-hanging fruit
okay you've models by mark months and
then it's got all the low-hanging fruit
that is in there aisel for [ __ ] like
this oh there's a shame open ready it's
so there's no tactics or anything it's
literally just I don't think you'd be
the best version of your so and be
surprised by anything in it it's just
you know what you know what you might
know this do you know what namaste means
I recognize the the infinite within you
the best in me and the best in you
yeah people water it down to me not
because it's nice it sounds less like
yeah okay well be infinite there were
the divine within okay so my my point
here is that a number of men may when
given the opportunity between honesty
and acceptability
a number of women as well but I can only
speak from a personal experience right
but this applies to women as much as it
does to man they have the choice between
honesty and acceptability and if your
honesty results in catastrophic body
odor or racial slurs every other word or
do you know I mean it's like you need to
there needs to be some sort of
being here yeah for the most part what
I'm talking about if someone who's maybe
got a particular an alternative
worldview or thinks about it
tries to distill concepts down in the
minor has a very active mind or maybe
suffers with depressive thoughts or
suffers with whatever it might be that
I'm talking from personal experience
here and you can rate this down by you
know there's certain elements of my
character and I don't want this to sound
like I'm proclaiming that like it's
showcasing myself but I know it's an
absolute fact that there will be less
women overall that are interested in you
your total area under the curve will be
less as a man in terms of finding a mate
okay being this particular level of
depth mm-hmm well I promise you this is
to every man that's listening or
watching out there you will talk there
under the curve you may suffer unless
you pull your acceptability
your honesty back in however every so
often you are going to strike a girl
that no one else can get I promise that
that's the way that it works that you
will get to the stage where a girl that
you've never ever thought would be
interested in you
or a friend that you never have a
thought or an opportunity that you never
thought that you would get this works
across a whole number 2 and the same for
girls as well and the reason for that is
that you're you are the equivalent of a
business that's servicing a niche market
and this market is completely completely
untapped and what they're doing is
they're making do with other businesses
that kind of get close to what they need
sit like a similar solution but not
quite what it's not quite what they want
and every so often this person is going
to find in you this unique blend a very
very enigmatic different values but
they're not going to be able to
replicate from someone and you have lost
you have got absolutely not and this is
the beauty this is one of the things I
was only discussion quite recently with
someone about this again guys they've
got this particular level of depth
mm-hmm a lot of the time because we are
presented the best of everyone else's
lives but yet we see the worst of our
own and this is in normal discourse no
one ever said you don't say how's your
day going any girl makes [ __ ] she
actually I woke up really depressed it's
indeed the candor is you're just doing
it it's a greeting right to say to say
hello we need to do a podcast on honesty
because it's such a it's a weight that
it's a core tenant of what I'm talking
about a lot of the time integrity virtue
honesty be true to yourself try not to
lie as much as possible etc etc so I'm
talking this guy saying look I'm aware
that you get to see your own blunders
from the the front a front row seat
right you see every single second of the
day and you only get to see the this
much the highlight reel at everybody
else's let's flip that on its head right
what you have as a man or as a woman who
sees that on depth is this really
colorful world where you have so much
debt so much variety of views and that
means that you and only you can be you
but when you see the highlight reel of
everyone else who are choosing
acceptability instead of honesty what do
you see there all you see is cookie
cutter design that's just replicated and
replicated and replicated over and over
so take that as your power like that is
someone who a person who has a
particular degree of debt is where you
can draw an awful lot of power from that
you go well hang on a second yeah cool
this person I thought was really good
for me or was this that me other and
that maybe it's worked out or maybe it's
not and
a little bit her or whatever and I
thought that they were there with this
girl I never thought this guy that I
thought I never get to be with and I
really really value them but you know I
see on Instagram and Facebook or on a
night out or at work I see [ __ ]
millions of people like them but I know
through personal experience that there's
only one of me I think that's a really
liberating thing to think really well
pearl well this has been something that
been that's been percolating around for
a little while and I've been trying to
distill it down I think it's very that
that distinction is probably more
prevalent in your world in the sense in
in the world that it that exists in the
my life of Newcastle then I think I feel
exposed to so maybe I think with it's an
interesting one with Chris because over
the last five six years at least since
we've known them what just no I'm not
going to say okay but we've we've seen
you on this path of becoming more
authentic becoming more comfortable with
your own with your own values that you
didn't feel were acceptable and becoming
more upfront with that the problem that
confounds this is that you haven't gone
down an acceptability because deep down
like you're you're a decent person you
know I said you know you said like if
your honesty is racial slurs and being a
prick and then you're actually trying to
be more acceptable by coating over that
then that's a different thing then
you've revealed someone who is it it's
fundamentally a good guy and the
authenticity in itself is an attractive
trait plus you are placed in a dominance
hierarchy quite high up because not sure
why that's why I wanted to try it and so
all of these factors plus like your a
beautiful month so thank you all these
things together alone in the bedroom
yeah let's let's do it and so so the
problem is like you you may be hot like
you haven't taken the hit on
acceptability by becoming more honest
because you have the other fundamentals
in place
agreed but it's also still I would sit
and say to today like my typical access
and I get to see the best cross-section
of potential partners right and this
works for men and for women I think
equally a night out is a pretty good
idea cuz it's a pretty ubiquitous
environment for people to be in not
everyone works at KPMG not everyone goes
to the gym but almost everybody goes on
nights out at some point yeah even if
it's once a year twice a year once a
week very good cross-section
representative sample yeah and I know
for a fact that I'm my access or my own
I must've changed the access on the end
Rangers of the bell curve probably
hasn't made much difference to the
incentive a possibility still still
can't relate to the vast majority of
people in the middle like you I imagine
you might sleep with a lot of them
because they because there's no there's
no nuance in that interaction and so
there's not chance for that to be
picked up on but then yeah your your
access and the depth of the voyage to
the the people who are the outliers
probably but remember and here's here's
the crux of the story and this is the
men and four women right I want this
particular element to read as a little
bit of a champion for romance to a
degree we're not talking here about like
how to shag as many people as possible
and you know there's strategies behind
that as well like you know there's an
entire culture for both men and women
above pickup artistry but this is more
about champion for romance right and for
whoever you are you only really need you
don't need to perform well in the league
games in the middle of October you only
need to win the Cup final once or twice
because as long as you're able to do
that and get that partner that you
really really [ __ ] desire and that
makes you feel a whole you only need to
get that once or twice and not [ __ ] it
and that's you set for life
it's not about like no one remembers the
guy that came 53rd in the world in the
cross the open but they remember the guy
that won and it's exactly the same as
that you only need to win and by getting
that but by using your deepness and your
uniqueness as a virtue and taking a lot
of power from that taking your power
from that it allows you to access these
people as potential partners who you
never would have done had you have
pushed yourself right into the middle of
the bell curve not only have you lied
about who you harm so that you're never
going to have a real connection with
this person and you're then potentially
trapped in this prison of pretending to
be this person for the rest of your life
which he never were so your level of
depth of connection at the beginning and
for all eternity until you die or break
up with them it is locked into this like
semi truthful approach you also get to
you get to have a partner that you feel
proud of because they love you for you
yeah there's an advantage over all and
not like I think in that sense you you
maybe don't need to take the hit on
acceptability in any in any case like
yeah it only opens up options it doesn't
close them off and the more you
understand yourself the more you can be
authentic in a relationship and the more
you can give in that as well so the next
question is how are you know that the
partners the right partner do you want
to do one on okay as well got an entire
framework for it he did but that's what
though was that song cuz I was gonna say
can we can we get on to these it's a
very big it's a very different path well
I think that we can probably close this
one there okay I think that we can draw
a line into this podcast and I'd said
before we start this one I wanted this
one to be as close to serious as we can
do we're about to roll in with Q&A which
is definitely not going to be serious
absolute video guide Dean I have
I've run out of battery on the g7x fYI
we can get a roundabout bang on an hour
of three 20-minute videos in there so if
you're listening please subscribe to the
modern wisdom YouTube channel we will be
coming back at some point soon when
we've got fresh cognitive capacity mmm
and we will be doing so it's whether to
decide to get into a relationship or not
how to decide who to be in a
relationship with and then some
principles to to see if that person
survived along to bother
everything from what we've discussed
forward I think the grateful I've
enjoyed today that's been awesome don't
forget to subscribe please make sure
that you follow program Fitness
appropriate fitness on everything online
actress will acts on Twitter all the
rest of the stuff you're not going to
add the text and it's feeling me are you
okay see this you have a little bit you
look like you've run a lander plane okay
okay bye then okay bye then
[Music]
you